[Musica]
poi però da posto bros colt devo dirti
una cosa importante dimmi veramente ci
rotto il ca posto sfondo e mi dispiace
dirtelo ma ogni giorno montevideo sempre
vedo quello sfondo blu lo sfondo della
numeretta basta dacci un taglio
in che senso
[Musica]
quindi puoi aiutarmi non ti preoccupare
ci penso io comunque non è che mi faccia
così tanto in impazzire se devo essere
sincero ma non neanche me c'è un po
troppo monocromatico non saprei come
spiegarlo è monotono non ho né braun
bravate dei guardare sempre stessa ora
un cammino che comunque strano perché
riccardo comunque vengono no lui già sa
magari siamo noi famoso per questo io
saremo noi che non cambia mai detto
faccio io ha detto ai due così al laccio
io è che la devo fare io vi ho detto
certo in casa bianca il tuo lavoro ti
fai degli oli noi se però non beach ma
forse allude di togliere questo anche
scusato
[Musica]
di questa frase che hai detto questo si
che uno sfondo ridi la mentre sei in
campo o questo sì che non spacca è
drammatico scusate questo virus a
allora ragazzi ben ritrovati nel mio
studio allora questo sfondo bellissimo
che vedete allora che per questo un pelo
buio ma la stiamo per risolvere proprio
oggi niente con questa cosa volevo
ringraziare richard e volevo ringraziare
daniele che tra un po conoscerete volumi
alzare jean soprattutto grazie anche a
lorenzo per lanciare il per avermi
seguito in tutto questo progetto e tutti
coloro che hanno partecipato alla
realizzazione di strisce questo sfondo
perché vi giuro che è porca vacca è
stato difficilissimo rifare al mio
studio per quanto sia picco perché
comunque nessuno e piccolo però serve
per fare video con i giusta di terni che
devi ballare la samba credo come
funziona questa cosa tu hai notato che
oltre questa fare qua bellissimo c'è
anche una ruota fantastica che tu che
prego la tua testa sarebbe questa
se fosse uscito il giallo davvero
incredibile allora serve e che in realtà
ragazzi questa è una ruota molto
particolare tipo quella di social
facebook la rotta là della sfortuna non
sappiamo perché chiamarla praticamente
tu cosa fai tu scrivi col pennarello su
questa precedente
se tu scrivi collo pennarello sulla
lavagna io non so scrivere
ok e gila ruota troppo la possibilità di
prendere giancarlo e io lo presi e
possiamo scrivere delle penitenze una
roba del genere che durante il gameplay
posso fare ad esempio la gialla stavano
pensando di fare solo pensando poi
ovviamente la cambieremo
inizia il gioco da capo che sarebbe
impossibile ma gente di baciatevi tipo
dieting over iter iniziato da capo
perché mi esce quella bisogna ancora
capire bene come attivare la ruota
magari sono proprio loro con i commenti
che possono dare qualche idea sul come
iniziare a girare la sai che sei proprio
bravo ogni tanto desidera scriveteci nei
commenti cose che noi non abbiamo voglia
di pensare che possiamo mettere sulla
ruota vi raccontiamo la roba che
comunque è successa perché allora
diciamo che io nei video mi porto avanti
e lui questo lo sa bene vuol dire che il
registro diversi video prima video
questo sfondo in realtà ce l'ho già da
una settimana e mezzo
uno di questi video è uscito prima dello
sfondo riveco che state vedendo adesso è
già uscito un video un verso sfondo
perché io pirla mi sono dimenticato di
tirare su rischi e quindi abbiamo già
spoilerato lo sfondo in un altro video
che è già uscito allora abbiamo deciso
di indie come come abbiamo deciso di
mascherare questa cosa non dicendo
niente aveva detto ieri la salma certo
aiuta che non ci sia dall'alto magari la
gente pensa che se una foto l'unar ti fa
cenno è proprio dopo uno sfondo volevamo
vedere un attimo quali sono state perché
comunque alcuni queste ne sono
ovviamente accordi
la reazione è stata questa ma vogliamo
parlare lo sfondo è bellissimo
non ho messo anche gorio del suo momento
lo sfondo della guerra 13 nel martello
che attinga belle e in cadute rover ande
e i favi lo sfondo la disegnato richard
htt quasi col non riconosciuto chi l'ha
disegnato e questa è un veramente un
tanto di cappello a ricevere addirittura
uno stile così prepotente da poter
essere riconosciuto di saldo stile tutto
allo stile pop among un bellissimo sono
diventate ormai siamo qui per forni un
certo radunare di rigine da cataldo
sfondi e non lo sono detto con la lotta
che dove dobbiamo darti noi delle idee
tutto quello che so niente ragazzi
quindi questo lo sfondo
adesso arriverà a richard e arriverà
daniele che mi ha aiutato invece nella
parte delle luci perché tutto stoccato
come facendo peluso 6 lo sappiano tappia
una cosa è lady ora che cos'è e cosa
venuti in mente lo sfondo che separa la
ruota no perché poi si devono fare le
cose non è così sanders atto quindi c'è
tutto un bordello
mi piace che l'hai detto punto incazzato
ed è giusto perché la gente non lo sa e
vero ci sono un miliardo di cose dietro
quello infatti pò le luci a guardare
così ecco così che hai facce di una mina
video così non si fanno i no non in
porca vacca e allora
mi sono beccato in tv sono le luci
tarate apposita cioè cose così che uno
dice ma perché non accendi direttamente
quella più grossa però almeno profondità
esatto vuoi ti rimane tutto schiacciato
ci vogliono un po di ombra in fascia
quindi adesso daniele arriverà su cioè
wow daniele allora se voi mi vedete nel
video è merito suo se no avrei la luce
spenta
no a parte gli scherzi allora quest'uomo
è per me dio perché nell'ultimo anno che
inizia macrico cagate è un anno che
facciamo sta roba dello studio petrali
ci togli luci metti luci invece adesso
grazie a daniele che introduce di un
attimo perché teme introduco cosa faccio
semplicemente io metto la luce metto la
luce nei sette creò la magia
così la chiama diciamo però lo fa in
modo professionale tecnico per gente che
ne capisce se non per noi
al lavoro per la televisione per il
cinema no però la televisione però una
cosa importante per esempio questo dico
io per i fatti miei però secondo me è
importante un po per tutti il nostro
amico a un canale youtube di cui parla
seriamente di queste robe che tra
l'altro è lo stesso nome delle luci che
usa ma è un caso nel caso il duomo di
eroina lacca eleano che la cube io lo
trovate in description perché veramente
mi ha cambiato la vita coi contate che
non capisco una mazza di luci ste cose
quindi grazie a quest'uomo mi vedete
bene ma tu spiega un po che cosa
nel disco di musica nonostante non è
nemmeno io
ma che ora vanta fra di turno è quello
che io di solito insegno e fare gli
accrocchi per il cinema è fatto di
accrocchi nastro isolante qui c'è la
imboscarsi ne facciamo il cinema ragazzi
e vado a fare il cinema ma da quanto
cinema che ciò e guarda che cinema che
ciò qua
guarda questo è spielberg è questo qua è
kubrick me stai guardando dio sceso in
terra
sto guardando dio cedente molto delle
luci vedete che illumina solo questo
lato di qua e non a parte i monitor
spegne
vai decenni visto se sono cagato dicevo
che mi cadesse in faccia comunque
ragazzi buon daniele ha registrato una
sorta di time laps di quando anno non è
una sorta contenta se mettiamo la
ragazza
[Musica]
chieti suoi sono state un sacco di cose
l'ultima roba che dobbiamo cambiare è il
computer perché questo computer nelle
c'è solo da un po di anni si era un po
io e il persona qua presente nonché mio
carissimo amico andremo a prendere il pc
nuovo e vi faremo vedere anche quello in
un inserto di un video prossimo c'è in
realtà doveva essere già in questo video
solo che abbiamo avuto dei contrattempi
e quella riva recha vabbè ma non saprei
come introdurti così prende veramente ci
pensavamo di essere stravagante la mia
vita poi ho conosciuto lorenzo non credo
io ho conosciuto richard basta eccoci
qua ma dov'è la bella miss tinagli per
fare proprio strano fine lo saranno fino
in fondo tengo anche questa sì sì
infatti mezza sporca da lavare gli dice
di sì e sì perché hai detto sì sì quindi
se ti va di siri mamma nonna
hai presente naturalmente lei dovuto
stampare su piu cosi mi sono fatto sotto
i fogli certo il consigliere impossibile
con i propri e comunque l'inizio del
video noi dicevamo proprio che tutti
hanno capito il tuo stile
se tutti a 96 anni ha detto la gente che
ti riconosce da il disegno c'è nel senso
non sanno che sei stato tu a farlo
perché non abbiamo detto niente la gente
giani come ti scrivo più grande richard
coop e quindi ragazzi questo è il mio
studio tutte le persone che vedete qui
hanno partecipato più web star channel è
veramente venuto fuori la cosa più
incredibile del mondo è piccolo ma nella
botte piccola che fa vj come sono
passate di mano che se volete passate
assolutamente sul canale i ragazzi
perché meritano un sacco di trote in
description è come sempre ricco che oggi
ci mancherebbe ci vediamo al prossimo
video come uno sfondo e delle luci
decenti da ragazzi
[Musica]